so the thing that it makes me think
about there is intellectual humility and
how tightly people hold on to their
beliefs that if you believe that you are
always going to be right that there is
nothing to learn outside of you and that
any kind of admission that you might be
wrong is tant amount to destruction it
does exactly the same thing you need to
and it goes back to uh asking stupid
questions being prepared to ask the
stupid questions and look not like the
most informed person in the room but
also importantly
nowhere near the most stupid person in
the room because you're the one that's
asking the question well the stupidest
person in the room is the person who
doesn't know and won't ask or even worse
who doesn't know and won't ask and acts
like they know that's not good at all
yeah there's a from your see that's part
of that idea that you should love your
enemy so you might say well why should
you do that well your enemy is going to
be your harshest
critic now it's possible that if you
have a very good enemy that he will show
you flaws in your character character
that you didn't know were there and so
that's a it's a
very it's a very strange way of looking
at the world to think that you should
welcome an attack you should it and this
is but this is right it yeah I'm saying
that with all due caution let's say the
most the more vicious the
attack the more of your potential hidden
flaws might be revealed have you found
that to true oh definitely but I've also
found
that the attacks force you to contend
with it to to see if it's there right to
to test it I suppose the attacks that
have come after me that have been most
successful they they're almost always
journalists and they're usually British
female journalists but not always we
produce a a nation of hard-hitting
journalists yeah well in faith in
journalists is the lowest in the UK and
anywhere in the western world and I can
see why you know but there's some
Advantage there's some real advantage to
facing someone it's a Pharisee problem
in in the
gospels Christ was always contending
with these Pharisees and what the
Pharisees were always trying to do was
to lay a verbal trap for him so he is
Pharisee a person Pharisee was a was a
Jewish sect okay and the Pharisees were
very legalistic in their interpretation
of Mosaic law and so they were sort of
they were hypocritical the way they're
portrayed in the gospel C is they're
hypocritical by the book moralists and
part of what and most of their morality
was for show they like to pray in public
they like to be seen being holy at least
that's the criticisms that are levied
against them and what they're always
trying to do in the gospel accounts is
to lay a verbal trap for Christ so that
they can expose him as a heretic and
kill him right so every single thing
they say is a snare of some sort and
there's lots of journalists like that
Nelly Bulls who wrote an article about
me for the New York Times which was a
very devastating article in many ways
and
very Serpentine and and
subtle she three years
later she wrote another article about
what it was like to work for the New
York Times when she was working there
and the tricks that the journalists
played including her and she said that
the game was to devastate someone else's
reputation in the attempt to boost yours
right so you could think about it as a
game of comparative moral standing so
the journalist's trick is to trick you
into saying something that will end your
career essentially their social status
stands on the shoulders of yours AB
absolutely absolutely and so now the the
advantage to being in a situation like
that is that you have to to step if you
step extremely
carefully and you're fortunate then you
evade the traps and then the interview
tilts hard in your favor yeah and so the
most the interviews that have done me
the most good in the long run were the
two interviews that were most hostile
one
by channels 4 Griffin Kathy Kathy Newman
Kathy Newman Kathy Griffin and Kathy
Kathy at least had a sense humor another
one by Helen Lewis who had no sense of
humor at all and doesn't seem to have
learned anything at all in the interim
but I think that I think that one has 80
million views now twice as many as the
Kathy Newman interview like it just
keeps racking up views and it was
because Helen
Lewis she has like 50 tricks or a 100
tricks Kathy had like four you know when
they were pretty blunt and she had a
sense of humor about them but Helen
Lewis she was just all tricks and lots
of and smart you know and it's quite
something to talk to someone who's quite
smart and quite educated but all tricks
and so but how does it feel looking back
on those two they were very formative
time it was kind of the inflection point
or one of the inflection points I
suppose for yourself as well yeah how
does it feel looking back on that I
remember you said at the time it took
you many days to recover from that kind
of cantankerous sort of adversarial
interview is that does that seem like a
different lifetime or is that still very
much sort of with you well I'm a lot
healthier than I was then so those sorts
of things wouldn't have the same effect
on me now as they did then because I was
Ill it took me a long time to recover
from you know a serious bout I mean the
first time I talked to Sam Harris not
that Sam played tricks like I like Sam
and we've had very productive
conversations I was so ill when the
first time I talked to Sam that I could
barely sit in my chair talking to Sam
Harris makes you ill that's the No No
not not at all no no Sam and I have had
very productive conversation so that was
another good example I suppose of the
utility of an adversarial conversation
yeah you know I mean Sam comes to a
conversation like that pretty well armed
but it's very helpful because it forces
you to look in nooks and crannies that
you might not have looked in and to be
crystal clear to the degree that that's
possible about what you're actually say
the idea of of loving your enemy is
something I've been playing with a
little bit recently there been I guess
my platform's getting to the level now
where uh there's a reason for someone to
have a bus I pointed at least remotely
in my direction because there's no point
in trying to take somebody down that's
got nothing that's got no status why
would you why would you invest the time
right you're the step that you're going
to get in terms of your status standing
on their shoulders is so small that no
one so it's a backhanded compliment yeah
in some ways um but you're right man
some of the some of the criticisms that
I've gotten I was reminded by a friend
recently about this
uh have been some of the best inflection
points very uncomfortable and to see it
as a gift to think about that thing as a
gift it's like I know that you weren't
doing this to make me better yeah I know
that you weren't doing this to try and
to try and benefit me and yet and yet
yeah in reflection it's like Alchemy
it's like how Rory Sutherland calls it
Alchemy taking something that was bad I
I had this reflection well we we've
learned my family's learned like when
when a public attack occurs
there's a massive opportunity nested in
it if you can reorient it's like okay
this is bad this is vicious this is not
this does not look good and maybe it
could take me out take us out is there a
way is there a way we can play with this
that will not only neutralize it but
twist it in the other direction I think
the thing we did that was most effective
on that side of things was when I was
written into Captain America as I spoke
to you that day I spoke to you that day
that it happened yeah the magical
magical super Nazi floating Nazi or
whatever yeah yeah yeah well it was
shocking right it was it was very
shocking and then Olivia wild yeah the
that was shocking too yeah yeah there's
a Litany of yes yes well and it it
became increasingly Preposterous and and
the Olivia wild episode was one of the
that was so Preposterous that it was
almost immediately I think mercifully
that film was so badly made and I'm
pretty sure that she'd cast her
boyfriend as one of the got rid of
someone that was super competent and put
somebody in that was pretty incompetent
uh and I think that that kind of caused
it to flub but yeah man the the the
enemy thing I've ended up becoming
really good friends with one of my
harshest critics it's so strange uh and
yet makes complete sense afterward we'll
get back to talking to Jordan in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about Maui Nei venison Maui Nei venison
is the most protein dense and
nutrient-dense red meat on the planet
thank you plus they're the only
stress-free 100% wild harvested meat
available my favorite method for cooking
it is straight from Frozen salt the hell
out of both sides 12 minutes in an air
fryer at maximum temperature turn it
over 12 minutes again and it is perfect
every single time it is such a life hack
actually taught to me by Jordan's
daughter Michaela and all she does is
eat meat so that's the way to do it all
of the cuts are spectacular but their
venison sticks have been my new favorite
while I've been traveling on the road
you can get the healthiest red meat on
the planet delivered directly to your
door by following the link in the show
notes below or going to Maui new venison
docomo wisdom using the code modern
wisdom at checkout that's 20% off by
going to M aui nuu venison docomo wisdom
and modern wisdom a
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with Jordan
you will love the over 3-hour long
podcast episode which is available right
here go
on give it a tap